first I got to ask you shocker you're
here in Vegas a lot of ladies are you
guys single
yeah thank you it's a good question I've
never before you never have love you
asked me that I'm really actually a bad
question for you right now
well Laurens single again a lot of fans
hopes you guys could get back together
will that happen you are the best are
you yeah so like the question is will we
get back together again you know I don't
think our lives have gone any closer
than they were a year and a half ago you
know if maybe they were aligning or
they're caught we were crossing past or
we haven't spoken I would say though
there's a shot but we've continued to go
like this and so I would say I don't I
don't see you that path or that
possibility happening at this point it's
weird you know it's a weird place but I
really do and I don't I just I hope for
the best for her I don't want to talk
about her breakup anymore
like I'm just I every time I talk about
I feel it again or like I think about it
and like we're both good we're doing our
thing well your thing includes
generosity now tell us about it
yeah generous international is best
known for our coffee but we have so many
tea drinkers out there that I think we
need to start generosity
what are you that official or is that an
idea it's an idea but if we're working
on it
yeah it's I mean we're working
you